Concord Kurt Vonnegut addresses the
110th graduating class of Agnes Scott
College along Decatur Georgia mr.
Vonnegut has written 11 novels or
slaughterhouse-five and more recently
time quake we must be very close to a
powerful transmitter for CNN right
anybody know where it is anybody know
where that transmitter is can't point it
out anybody know where Jane Fonda is now
in the early days of radio I remember
people living too close to the
transmitter of station KDKA and
pittsburgh used to hear soap operas in
their bridge work and their mattress
Springs and now CNN plays such a big
part in the lives of so many Americans
including my own that we might as well
be hearing Wolf Blitzer in Christiania
Amanpour in our bridge work and mattress
Springs well I won't lie to you today
the news from CNN can be really bad but
I also give you my word of honor that
you before me the class of 1999 at Agnes
Scott College are near the very top of
the very best best news I can ever hear
by working as hard at becoming wise and
reasonable and well-informed you have
made our little planet a saner place
than it was before you got here so thank
you for that god bless you and the
Faculty of this College and those who
made it possible for you to go from
strength to strength here thanks to all
of you the forces of ignorance and
brutality have lost again not that there
hasn't been a lot of good news along
with the bad long before you got here
I'm talking about the birth of works of
art music painting statues buildings
pong stories plays essays and movies you
bet and humane ideas which make us feel
honored to be members of the human race
what can you yourselves contribute well
you've come this far
anyway and it wasn't easy and then I
recited a famous line by the poet Robert
Browning with one small change I have
replaced his word man which in this time
was taken to mean human being with the
word word him with the word woman may I
say to that his wife Elizabeth Barrett
was as great a poet as he was is how do
I love thee let me count the ways and so
on while I'm at it get a little - this
the atomic bomb which we dropped on the
people of Hiroshima was first envisioned
by a woman not a man she was of course
Mary Wollstonecraft Shelley she didn't
call it an atomic bomb she called it the
monster of Frankenstein the back -
Robert Browning and what he said about
anyone who hopes to make the world
better again I've changed the word man
to woman for this occasion
a woman's reach should exceed her grasp
or what's a heaven for and of course the
original a man's grasp should exceed his
reach or what's a heaven for now
speaking of women Pollyanna
is not your graduation speaker here
today Pollyanna is bound to be speaking
somewhere irrepressibly optimistic
seeing good and everything so I will
comment is briefly and efficiently as
possible on the perfectly horrible news
cNN has been giving us about the Balkans
and that high school in Colorado I won't
go on and all about it we're here for a
good time and we are darn well going to
have one others met with axes to grind
are playing the blame game blaming the
National Rifle Association the movies TV
pop music video games no prayers in the
school
I myself have an ax which I have ground
as sharp as a razor what would I like to
do with it if I could I would like to
plant it in the forehead of the
Babylonian king Hammurabi
who lived almost 4000 years ago now
Hammurabi gave us a coat which is
honored to this very day by many nations
including our own and by all heroes in
cowboy and gangster films and by far too
many people who feel that they have been
insulted or injured however slightly
however accidentally and eye for an eye
a tooth for a tooth revenge is not only
sweet revenge is a must
what antidote can there be for an idea
that popular and poisonous revenge
provokes revenge which is sure to
provoke revenge forming an endless chain
of human misery here's the antidote
forgive us our trespasses as we forgive
those who trespass against us amen now
some of you may know that I'm a humanist
not a Christian but I say if Jesus is
all humanists do if what he said was
good and so much of it was absolutely
beautiful what can it matter if he was
God or not if Christ hadn't delivered
the Sermon on the Mount with its message
of mercy and pity I wouldn't want to be
a human being I'd rather be a
rattlesnake okay now let's have some fun
let's talk about sex
let's talk about women Freud said he
didn't know what women wanted well I
know what women want they want a whole
lot of people to talk to what do they
want to talk about they want to talk
about everything what do men want well
they want a lot of pals and they wish
people wouldn't get so mad at them all
the time now why are so many people
getting divorced today it's because most
of us don't have extended families
anymore it used to be that when a man
and a woman got married the bride got a
whole lot more people to talk to about
everything the groom got a whole lot
more pals to tell dumb jokes too now a
few Americans but very few still have
extended families the Navajos the
Kennedys but most of us if we get
married today
are just one person for the other person
the groom gets one more pal but it's a
woman what woman gets one more person to
talk to about everything but it's a man
when a couple has an argument nowadays
they may think it's about money or sex
or power or how to raise the kids or
whatever what they're really saying to
each other though is you're not enough
people I met a man in Nigeria one time
an ebow who had six hundred relatives he
knew quite well his wife had just had a
baby the best possible news in any
extended family they were going to take
take that kit to meet all its relatives
ebo zuv all ages and sizes and shapes it
would even meet other babies cousins not
much older than it was everybody was big
enough and steady enough was going to
get to hold it to cuddle it to gurgle to
it and say how pretty it was or how
handsome wouldn't you have loved to be
that baby now I sure wish I could wave a
wand and give every one of you and
extended family make you an ebow or a
Navajo or a Kennedy least I can do is
give you health tips I've already
mentioned sunscreen and don't smoke
cigarettes which are as evil as slobodan
milosevic
but cigars are good for you yeah they
are so helpful that there is a magazine
devoted to their enjoyment with cigar
smoking role models on the cover
athletes movie stars rich guys why not
the Surgeon General cigars of course are
made of trail mix a blend of raisins
cashews and granola which has been
soaked for a week in maple syrup so to
celebrate at the end of your graduation
day why don't you eat a cigar at bedtime
no cholesterol guns are also good for
people no nicotine and no cholesterol
ask your congressperson if that isn't
true incidentally if somebody ask you
whether you are a liberal or
conservative tell them this listen
buster I'm a graduate of Agnes State
College in Decatur GA tip code three
zero zero three zero they taught me to
think for myself there you want to know
if I'm a liberal or conservative I'm
both of those and neither one go jump in
the lake go climb a tree are so far
quoted Robert and Elizabeth Barrett
Browning and Hammurabi and Jesus Christ
I now give you Sir William Gilbert of
the team of Gilbert and Sullivan I often
think it's comical how nature always
does contrive that every boy in every
gal that's born into the world alive is
either a little liberal
all or a little conservative while I'm
at it why don't I give you Eugene Victor
Debs the great Labour leader who ran for
president three times on the socialist
ticket and who died in 1926 when I was
four years old as long as there is a
lower class I'm in it as long as there
is a criminal element I am of it as long
as there is a soul in prison I am NOT
free now that's worth repeating as long
as there's a lower class I'm in it as
long as there is a criminal element I am
of it as long as there is a soul in
prison I am NOT free wouldn't you like
to say that when you get out of bed
every morning with the roosters crowing
as long as there is a lower-class how a
minute as long as there's a criminal
element I'm of it as long as there's a
soul in prison I am NOT free excuse me I
beg your pardon I'm receiving signals
from CNN and my bridgework Wolf Blitzer
and Christiana Amanpour Wolf Blitzer and
Christiana almond pork women say CNN's
military consultants are unanimous in
feeling that our revenge on the Serbs
for their revenge on the Kosovars has
gone about as well as could be expected
the code of hammurabi
revenge I for an eye a tooth for a tooth
always works that way about as well as
can be expected
wait a minute somebody else is speaking
no it's not wolf it's not crystianna
whoever it is and I'll bet she's blonde
okay
she's saying I can lose 30 pounds in 30
days and never once feel hungry okay
she's gone now thank goodness my bridge
work has fallen silent of its own accord
I thought for a minute there is going to
have to ask somebody for dental floss
hi-tech how would that have been for a
high-tech tuning out CNN with dental
floss how I love hi-tech Forbes magazine
asked a bunch I was a while back the
name our favorite technologies I said
the Encyclopedia Britannica on a shelf
because it's alphabetical my address
book also alphabetical and the mailbox
on the corner putting a letter in the
mailbox is like feeding a great big
bullfrog painted blue you know what it's
lid says to me when I close it ribbon it
says don't give up on books they feel so
good they're friendly heft and sweet
reluctance of their pages when you turn
them with your sensitive fingertips a
large part of our brains is devoted to
deciding whether what our hands are
touching is good or bad for us any brain
worth a nickel those books are good for
us
computers are insincere books are
sincere and don't try and make yourself
an extended family out of the scoops on
the Internet get yourself a Harley and
join Hells Angels instead all right
let's stop kidding around and get down
to the nitty-gritty you know what you
are class in 1999 you are a bunch of
Eve's and now that you've eaten the
Apple of knowledge you're getting kicked
out of here
Hey
many of you intend to become teachers
which is the noblest of all professions
in a democracy teachers can be so good
for this country but only if their
classes can be cut to 18 teaching his
friendship and nobody can deal
intelligently was more than 18 friends
at any given time and only well-informed
warm-hearted people can teach others
things they'll always remember in love
computers and TVs can never do that a
computer teaches a child what a computer
can become an educated human being
teaches a child what a child can become
now some of you will become mothers
these things happen if you should find
yourself sidelined in this fashion
remind yourself of these lines by the
19th century white male poet William
Ross Wallace the hand that rocks the
cradle rules the world that being the
case you might teach the kid a couple of
things that should say every day forgive
us our trespasses as we forgive those
who trespass against us
and as long as there's a soul in prison
I'm not free ideals too attainable class
of 1999 let me impress on you that
ideals by their very definition can
never be too high for children or anyone
a child's reach should exceed its grasp
or what's a heaven for now this
wonderful speech is almost nearly twice
as long as the most efficient effective
oration in the in American history which
is Abraham Lincoln's Gettysburg Address
Lincoln incidentally was killed by a
two-bit actor exercising his right to
bear arms
up to now most of what I've said has
been a custom job for this
Dixieland rite-of-passage but every
graduation pep talk I've given has ended
with words about my father's brother
Alex Vonnegut a harvard-educated
insurance agent in Indianapolis who was
well-read and wise the first graduation
at which I spoke incidentally was also
at what was then a woman's college
Bennington in Vermont the Vietnam War
was going on in the graduates wore no
makeup to show how ashamed and sad they
were but about my uncle Alex who's up in
heaven now one of the things he found
objectionable about human beings was
that they so rarely noticed when they
were happy he himself did his best to
acknowledge that when times were sweet
we could be drinking lemonade in the
shade of an apple tree in the summertime
and uncle Alex would interrupt the
conversation to say if this isn't nice
what is so I hope that you adorable
women before me will do the same for the
rest of your lives when things are going
well sweetly and peacefully please pause
a moment and then say out loud if this
is nice what is let me let that be the
motto of the Agnes Scott College class
of 1999 if this isn't nice what is now
that's one favor I've asked of you now I
ask for another one ask it not only of
the graduates but for everyone here
including President Mary Brown Bullock
were you
I want to show of hands after I ask this
question
keep your eyes on dr. Bullock how many
of you have had a teacher at any level
of your education who made you more
excited to be alive prouder to be alive
then you had previously believed
possible hold up your hands please
what's she doing okay all right now take
down your hands and say the name of that
teacher to someone sitting or standing
near you
all done this isn't nice what is
[Applause]